look at this it's just sitting on a
chair i don't even know what's going on
[Music]
bam there you go [__] double
periscope who doesn't like this
late night we might as well get our head
together
you ain't got nothing to do anyway
you're sitting there [__] staring up
at the bedroom
thinking what's gonna happen with my
life [__] it with uncle joe
[Music]
we got [__] still wish you were here
on tonight
welcome to the [__] machine cop
suppers that's what we got
going on here machine we got a little
bit of weed left
wait what are you gonna smoke a little
bit of what
[Music]
we're smoking cigars what
bad [__] when was the last time
you say ellie's damon
[Music]
huh when's the last time you saw this
[__] aerosmith i'm telling you
don't go nowhere
oh [__] we might have to go deep with
you [__]
and bring you back what do you think of
that tonight
[__] enough for pink floyd
i don't want to have dreams of devils
and [__] like that i want to have nice
dreams of people sucking my dick on
quaaludes licking my [__] and [__]
like that you understand
you get your [__] linked on a monday
night you have no [__] idea my friend
people will pay 200 to get a good
[__] ball combination [__] wait
maybe in the old days you got a black
hooker they're doing around the world
for a buck and a quarter
you ever have it around the world that's
when they suck your balls
they suck yeah so they suck your dick
then when you come they take the hot [__]
and they spit it in your [__]
tremendous
it's a [__] party for some people you
know
then your balls are digging and it
tastes like [__] like there's a [__]
leg
what do you think your balls in your
dick taste like now paradise you just
smoked your [__] [__]
you even [__] subway [__] something
you know what your [__] smells like
it smells like [__] sand headset
that's what it smells like
i'm gonna drop a bad [__] album
on you [__]
you might as well get a quaalude and
dose the neighbor
[__] when's the last time you dosed the
neighbor you're [__] coming the right
ball and you [__] change your address
you know what i'm saying
here we go oh [__]
one of the classics of my youth you know
how many [__] gorilla biscuits
i [__] ate to the sound tremendous
[Music]
oh [__] we're going down turn out the
lights lee
[__] it she came from planet clare there
you go who's
look at this [__] huh living like
doctors and [__]
cali
[Music]
here we go you're getting down with
uncle joey
late night here oh [__] oh [__] here you
go cop suckers
two periscopes at once who doesn't like
that here you go
oh [__] what are you doing cop sucking
don't [__] miss out on uncle joey i'm
talking to them
i didn't forget about you
[Music]
get up throw your pajamas out the window
it's over
anybody can go to work on a tuesday be
original oh [__]
oh [__] be original tell that boss to
suck your dick
you are partying with uncle joey's fun
house and [__]
oh [__] honey
what
it's that time oh [__]
we're going deep auschwitz backwards
[Music]
[Laughter]
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with [__]
some [__] neighbor all these fake
[__]
with a poster on their wall of reefer
this is uncle joey 925
pacific what have you done today
[Music]
[__]
oh [__]
the planet claire i know she came from
there
[Music]
listen to this [__] right here faster
than the speed of light
oh [__]
all the trees
[Music]
the [__] you think you're dealing with
[__] there's the uncle joey show
[__]
[Music]
oh [__]
[__] it she's from mars
[Music]
oh [__] here we go [__]
1979 b-52s
out of georgia throwing [__] heat
two little [__] gay dudes two chicks
and a [__] heroin addict on a guitar
this is some of the best [__] guitar
you will ever hear in your goddamn life
underrated this guy and the guy from the
[__] car a little guy from long
island
here we go [__] kick your [__]
tell your wife to get up and suck your
dick
we're going back to kaplan school [__]
oh [__] get the surfboard out
see i'm on the beach
can conan o'brien do this [__] no
how about [__] jimmy fallon suck my
dick and the other [__] englishman
licked my [__]
nobody throws a late night party like
uncle joey's solo
and [__] oh [__]
oh [__]
what are you [__] kidding me or what
this is late night tv [__] call
your congressman
call your [__] senators get the
priest on the phone
tell him jimmy fallon to suck your dick
it's the jungle uncle joey midnight hour
hook is dying explosives people get
[__] in the ass
but most importantly music
reefer and lisa
[Music]
wake up [__] america's dying [__]
trump [__] trump
[__] cruz [__] fubio whatever his
[__] name is
rubio [__] hillary clinton
and [__] the other guy we're taking over
ourselves we'll be our own [__]
presence
are you [__] kidding me or what don't
go nowhere we're coming back with more
[__] music
[Music]
oh
you [__] think you're dealing with
people and now for our word for my
sponsors
are you depressed lonely go get a
medical marijuana license to change your
life like i did
i used to be a schlub i would sit at
home and eat my toenails
no more now i smoke reefer and i have a
life i have friends
and i have music that's all that matters
if you're looking for a good medical
marijuana store
go to sunset herbal on burp bank
boulevard
[__] perennial on ventura this is a
[__] ad
i don't know who brought this for you
marijuana marijuana that's it
we're back [__] what the [__] you
think you're dealing with
that wasn't me that was the commercial
dude get your bowl ready [__]
what can we listen to to end the night
what do you think people
a little doors a little ac dc little
doors
that's anything in the [__] doors
tonight all right
i got a little l.a woman for you
[__]
[Music]
listen i don't know what you know or
what you don't know
in my world when i was young i didn't
like the [__] doors i thought he was
a sack of [__]
but then i started reading up on him and
i started listening to his music and
where he was coming from
and then i said this [__] is
deep
but this album here my mom used to play
this album when i was three [__]
years old you understand me
are you [__] with me [__] when
i was a kid my mom used to play this
album for me so
that's how long it's been in my [__]
la woman
to me is one of the greatest songs of
all [__] time
because it changes melodies like ten
times
oh [__] do you remember when you were my
man
oh [__]
give me a little hit i gotta find the
[__] doors for you [__] now
yeah songs don't change tempo anymore do
they no
all one same thing all the way through
no this is uh
oh [__] oh [__]
oh [__] you might have to get the heroin
you might have to break into grandma's
pill [__] closet we might have to
melt that [__] down
and shoot that my [__] toes you
understand me i'm putting the doors on
now
this is where it gets ugly [__]
here we go
what you never melted grandma's pillows
it's a [__] party
you get a little [__] syringe it's
all over you shoot it right in your
[__] forehead like a hindu
and then you put like a scotch tape or
whatever the [__] they do
before the carry juice flies out here we
go
[Music]
it's too much too much
it's too much
listen if i had the allman brothers live
from fillmore
i would tell you it's all to get the
tylenol we'll just kill each other
on periscope wouldn't that be nice like
80 of us just kill each other
just commit suicide on periscope if i
had to [__] feel more east now
that's what we do tonight we smoke dope
and just dial 9-1-1
[Music]
who [__] likes this music
oh [__]
[Music]
changes tempo five [__] times
opens up there at the beach it's just
too much
it opens up spooky listen to this [__]
is one of the deepest [__] songs
you'll ever hear whether i'm driving
taking a shower it always brings a tear
to my [__] eye just jam
just takes you somewhere different right
now tremendous
i advise you get the pipe ready lock the
door it's over
here we go third [__] music change
here we go number four
become something else [__] brilliant
just just just
listen jump off the [__] bridge right
now
jump don't get no better than this
[Music]
come on [__] that's it rihanna
can't do this
the [__] fool fighters can't do this
nobody can do this
nobody are you [__] nuts
[Music]
charge granted
come on get the cd get the eye i don't
care
this is a [__] this will set you free
i swear to god
i don't make no i'm telling you as
you're [__] uncle joey i'm telling
you
whatever you like i don't like that i
don't give a [__] what you like
get this this will change your [__]
life forever like it did for me
[Music]
and if you don't believe me go to your
[__] netflix and get
the doors live from the hollywood bowl
1969.
i'm telling you i'm telling you watch
this dude it's a [__]
it's a history lesson [__] ain't lincoln
[__] world war ii [__] pearl harbor i'm
telling you this
this is american [__] history
[__]
all ten [__] songs is history
don't make me get [__] excited don't
make me get up [__] suckers
don't make me get up i swear to god
let me get a tissue dog i'm over here
[Applause]
thank you my brother
again another [__] music change now
he's johnny bolero playing [__]
spanish music
here we go
[Music]
lyrics are [__] just beautiful
hills are filled with fire
[Music]
if they say i never love you you know
they are a lion
just beautiful just beautiful [__]
[Music]
don't come in here officer i'll [__]
stab you
right here this is beautiful motel money
murder madness come on [__]
what who the [__] you think you're
dealing with
i'm getting tired from all this [__]
talking about music [__]
you're lucky i had a protein shake
tonight some sushi
i did have a little philly roll tonight
i couldn't eat anything else
i just had to get the sushi here we go
people
here's where it takes you for a [__]
psychological mind [__]
some people say he did this took his
dick out one time and jerked off on
stage
and [__] that's why mr mojo was rising
jack
that's what he's saying [__] yeah he
took his dick out a bunch of time
[Music]
you gotta love this [__] did you ever
see him take a dig no i was a kid
he died like 72 or something
[Music]
mr mojo's rising [__] time to wake
your wife up
tell us you stiff in the helmet it's
over you don't give a [__] what times
you gotta get up
it's over here we go
[Music]
[__]
guitar
listen to that [__] guitar jesus
christ
[Music]
are you [__] yay
too much people the doors l.a woman the
whole album
is a [__] masterpiece order it right
now
download it if you don't [__] shoot
yourself
because it's over for you [__]
i'll see you [__] tomorrow
same bat time same bad channel
[Music]
with a little girl and a hollywood
bungalow
are you [__] nuts in the city of
lights
where the [__] are you you're not in the
city of lights cop sucker
neither am i i'm in studio city i see
you [__] suckers tomorrow stay black
[Music]